a favor de este jardín no queda casi
nada inscripción en pleno corazón de
crema torch los ataques rusos
despertaron a los habitantes en plena
noche estábamos durmiendo cuando a las 2
15 de la mañana llegó un misil y se
rompieron las ventanas
salimos a la calle y vimos un gran
agujero en el jardín ellos pueden
considerarse afortunados porque más al
norte en jarkiv otros ataques alcanzaron
a civiles el resultado al menos un
muerto y varios heridos las autoridades
acusan a rusia de actos deliberados
contra civiles supermarket
hay un supermercado edificios
residenciales no hay fuerzas armadas ni
defensa territorial ni policía aquí no
hay nada de eso el ataque se llevó a
cabo para matar a civiles
puesto y también extensivo en el este de
ucrania continúan los intensos combates
en la línea del frente
jarquín trama torch y dones que están
siendo afectadas por numerosos ataques
rusia está estancada en el donbass pero
la destrucción aumenta
en slogans ya no hay agua potable ni
electricidad en las casas los ciudadanos
acuden a abastecerse en los surtidores
públicos que aún están intactos
de que no haya algo es un verdadero
problema al que puedes lavar nada no
puedes hacer nada no se puede hervir la
comida
a finales de julio el presidente
selenski pidió a los habitantes que
evacuaran la región pero muchas de las
200.000 personas afectadas siguen
viviendo allí